I haven't watched baseball. I can't get, I haven't gotten into this.
I couldn't even the Island is, I'm a big Island, just fan.
They're going to probably go to the standard. The NHL has been great.
I just can't for me, man. I don't know why it's just not having the fans there.
Everything seems like pre-season, everything seems like exhibition.
And I realized that I played sports my whole life and I it's one of those things
I'm like, do I not love sports? Cause if I can't watch it without the fans, why,
why was I even watching it to begin with?
I think I used to just do it because it's what my dad would make me do.
And now he moved to Florida and has he's on dialysis. So who knows?
He's he's unconscious half the time, but he's got a little watch it.
He's got a little bit of your money.
So he's got some money to play around with my dad's got some juice on the games.
Yeah. It's what it is. Did that guy, uh, did he force you to play sports?
He did that that's the, that was the thing.
Like my mother would always say when I was a kid, she was like, you know, Tony,
that he doesn't want to play. And then he'd be like, you know, my dad was like,
no, he does want to play it. I'm like, I really don't want to play it.
He's like, you're going to play. And then I would just play, you know,
basketball and baseball. And I remember once, I mean, like there was no,
I remember one time I got hit by a pitch. We were playing baseball.
I got hit by a pitch. It was like 11 years old. I was crying and home played.
I just want someone to comfort me and my dad just, you know, coaching the game,
walks out and he's like rubbing my back. You know? He's like,
you got to stop crying. You're embarrassing me. I'm like my back hurts.
I don't want to play the game. He's like, are you really going to be this,
the name on the back of your Jersey? You're embarrassing me. He was like,
I can not wait.
I cannot wait to get home because I'm going to beat the out of you.
And then I was just, you know, they never happened, but I was just, yeah,
I think for so much of my life, I just played sports because my dad,
you know, would just make it,
I don't like division two scoring record Korean.
I'm running score in my college and I never wanted to play the game,
but I would just still shoot a thousand jump shots every day, just play,
you know, baseball, basketball.
It was just because I wanted my dad to be proud of me. And uh, you know,
I guess at the end he kind of was,
did you look back after your playing career and be like, what the hell was that?
Or was it while you were doing it? Um, like the last six months,
did you realize, like I got to stop doing this cause this wasn't my dream.
I think that it's just,
we were talking about before about like addictions and stuff like that.
I think that it's just all I've done.
My whole life is just change addictions that I've had,
like first it was basketball and sports because my dad was like,
this is what you want to do. And I was like, I want my dad to love me.
I want my dad to be proud of me. I'm addicted to that.
Cause he left and my family was divorced and I'm like, dad,
this will make dad proud. A thousand jumps shots and then boom, basketball,
accolades, accolades, accolades. And then it stops and I'm like, Oh,
I don't want to play anymore. So then it turned to, uh,
getting my mother's love. Cause my mother would say,
I remember my mother said to me once when I was 21, she was like, you know,
I feel like you do everything for your father and you won't do anything for me.
She's like,
I feel like you're such a smart kid and you've never applied yourself
academically. And that's all I ever wanted. And,
and all you ever did was prove stuff to your dad.
So then I got into graduate school and got a doctorate degree and got a
doctorate in physical therapy because I swear to God, I did it from my mother.
Just, just like putting my head down and doing it, doing it, doing it.
And then I'm doing physical therapy for a year and I said, this.
I don't want to do this. I want to do some for me.
And then I went to the golf and comedy club, open mic,
and then I've just been doing this ever since.
So I think I've just changing addictions.
And then eventually this'll probably Peter out and I don't know what I'll do
after this needs to do is now put pressure on you to become the greatest
cohost in the short time of podcasting history. Then you'll,
you'll you'll achieve that too. We really hope you.
You enjoyed that episode, whatever it was about,
this is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe, uh,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys where things get really
wild.